à la verrière commune urbaine de plus de
6000 habitants quatre candidats sont en
lice pour les élections municipales de
2020 premier adjoint au maire depuis
2014 jean yves les portes la liste
ensemble la verrière citoyenne un
rassemblement de la plupart des élus
ayant créé un groupe au sein de la
majorité sur fond de désaccord avec la
mer fin 2018 une divergence notamment
sur la rénovation du bois de l'étang
jean yves blais son équipe veulent une
démolition partielle avec reconstruction
on veut relancer une attractivité pour
notre ville notre ville se meurt les
gens partent ne veut pas y rester
on voit on discute avec les gens et nous
notre souhait qui vivons là c'est de
dire à ces gens là non vous devez rester
il ya il ya des choses possibles on il
ya des choses intéressantes à vivre sur
cette commune mais ressortent antonelli
duthu se présente pour poursuivre son
mandat débuté en 2016 après la démission
d'alain ajaj militante communiste elle
siège au sein du conseil municipal de la
verrière depuis 2008
elle propose un projet social aux
habitants de la verrière teintée
d'écologie le social prime parce qu'on
est dans une ville très populaire où les
gens
on pas beaucoup d'argent voire beaucoup
moins sous le seuil de pauvreté
nous on se doit de rétablir un peu
d'égalité là dedans d'un peu de justice
sociale l'attend en essayant de de les
aider le mieux possible et le plus
concrètement possible quoique ça donne
des résultats
premier adjoint au maire de la verrière
de 1983 à 1989 gérard claude morfin
aussi occupé la vice présidence du
syndicat communautaire d'aménagement de
l'agglomération
puis du syndicat d'agglomération
nouvelle entre 1995 et 2001 architecte
de profession il s'engage dans ce
scrutin avec une liste citoyenne
l'idée nouvelle c'est de permettre des
personnalités de quartier de prendre
place dans une équipe citoyenne et de
leur permettre de s'exprimer avant
l'élection conseiller municipal
d'opposition de la verrière depuis 2014
nicolas d'un vide entre dans la sphère
politique en 2011 en tant que
collaborateur parlementaire auprès du
député-maire jean-michel fourgous depuis
2010 est il est conseiller départemental
il se lance avec une liste ouverte
c'est à la fois fectivement
l'aboutissement d'un long travail on
était dans l'opposition depuis six ans
on a été très présent sur le terrain
avec mon équipe dans les conseils
municipaux dans les commissions on n'a
jamais lâché
et puis c'est aussi le renouveau puisque
on a envie d'apporter du sang neuf une
nouvelle vision